[Musik]
herzlich willkommen tantra da denkt man
vielleicht an indien und 16 aber was ist
tantra eigentlich kann sexualität zur
erleuchtung führen und wie kommt es dazu
dass diese hinduistisch puristische
strömungen im westen so verbreitet ist
diesen fragen gehen wir heute nach für
ein mann in einer begegnung der
sternstunden philosophie und religion
meine kollegen die sportart sehen sie
später er hat im vorfeld eine der
weltweit bekanntesten tantra lehrerinnen
getroffen
zuerst stelle ich ihnen aber unsere
heutigen studiogäste vor bei mir ist
lieber marx ist tantra massagen und
sechs logische körpertherapeut mit
studio in zürich
auch bei uns ist sophie werner scheid
sie ist kulturwissenschaftlerin und
professorin für skandinavische literatur
in kopenhagen und aus berlin
zugeschaltet ist uns jan ullrich sobisch
er ist die pathologie an der ruhr
universität bochum
schön dass sie hier sind herzlich
willkommen dankeschön
ja frau mag ich habe es gerade gesagt
sie sind tantra masseurin sie waren
einst mal im marketing tätig was ist
genau geschehen
ja das ist eine spannende reise für mich
gewesen und zwar hat die schon in meiner
jugend begonnen da hatten haben mich die
themen sexualität und spiritualität
bereits interessiert ich habe bücher
verschlungen über das leben nach dem tod
aber auch meine freundin ausgequetscht
über ihre ersten sexuellen erfahrungen
und dann in meinen 20 er jahren habe ich
das erste mal über die weibliche
ejakulation erfahren und dachte wie kann
das sein dass ich in einer solch
aufgeklärten gesellschaft lebe aber dass
es doch immer noch große tabu themen
gibt weil man darüber nicht bescheid
weiß genau also wir haben es nicht
gelernt im aufklärungsunterricht und
eben jetzt auch sonst ein tabuthema frau
spricht nicht darüber die männer genauso
wenig und dann habe ich anfang 30 meine
erste tantra massage erleben dürfen und
das war augen öffnen für mich weil ich
da mein körper das erste mal ganz anders
gespielt habe auch meine lust und ich
hatte auch ein zustand erlebt
ich ihn sonst nur vom meditieren gekannt
habe also diese quasi erotisch erfahrung
war auch eine klar eine spirituelle
erfahrung dann genau
und da habe ich gemerkt war das ist
eigentlich genau das sind die zwei
komponenten die mich schon so lange
faszinieren spiritualität auf der einen
seite dass das geistige aber auch dieses
körperliche verwurzelte und das tantra
diesem spagat irgendwie auch schafft
oder der der neo daran tragen es ist ja
nicht jede tantrische strömung darüber
wie auch meine sexualität umfasst und da
habe ich gespürt dass das etwas ist
diese tantra massage dass sich ja auch
anderen menschen zugänglich machen und
so habe ich dann mit der sexy logischen
körpertherapie zuerst angefangen und
dann auch tantra massage
die ausbildung dazu gemacht und das ist
jetzt eine riesen freude für mich
menschen in diese räume begleiten zu
dürfen
die frau wird als
kulturwissenschaftlerin was interessiert
sie denn genau am campra also über
tantra kann ich nicht so viel sagen aber
über sexualität begehren erotik da kann
ich einiges
genau darüber damit habe ich mich schon
lange beschäftigt also ist ja eines der
themen der großen themen in der
literatur in der kunst natürlich auch
sexualität ist etwas was uns in unserem
leben als person ganz in einem ganz
intimen maße ausmacht unser sein in der
welt unser verhältnis und selber unser
verhältnis zu anderen wird maßgeblich
als intimus als sexuelles verhältnis
bestimmt das ist schon mal als
philosophisches thema unglaublich
spannend aber auch als historisches
thema also obwohl sexualität etwas ganz
privates und persönliches ist ist unser
sexuelles erleben natürlich auch immer
eingebunden an historischen kontext
müssen nur zurückschauen die letzten 70
jahre
wie sehr sich unser verständnis von
sexualität verändert hat 70er jahren der
große aufbruch die große befreiung
sexuelle revolution in den 90er jahren
vielleicht eher so eine gewisse ermüdung
eine
lust statt einer wollust und heute neue
möglichkeiten durch eine technologische
über formte sexualität sexualität im
virtuellen raum also da sehen wir wie
sehr sich sexualität verändert wie sehr
sich unsere auffassung auch von begehren
verändert wie sehr sich unser
körpergefühl verändert wie wir auch
immer wieder neu zugang finden müssen
also und da kommt ankara als möglichkeit
sicherlich ein ganz besonderer weise ins
spielen genau das finde ich jetzt
interessant was würden sie denn sagen
weshalb das wäre erklärungsversuch
weshalb dieses angebot an diesem neo
tantra auch so boomt hierzulande um
nicht nur hier also ich kann mir
vorstellen dass das tatsächlich was mit
einer zunehmenden technologisierung und
digitalisierung zu tun hat an deren
vorteile ja auf der hand liegen gerade
jetzt auch in einer zeit wo wir
gezwungen sind abstand zu wahren
aber dieses abstand wahren müssen
erinnert uns natürlich auch daran wie
sehr wir uns nach begegnung sehen wie
sehr wir uns nach unmittelbarkeit sehnen
einen zurückfinden zu sich selber eine
in berührung kommen mit sich selber mit
seiner umwelt lauf auf neue weise
ich glaube das macht einen reiz von
tantrischen praxen aus wie wir es aber
auch in anderen zusammenhängen sehen
können also werden wir sicherlich noch
darauf zu sprechen kommen aber auch in
der philosophie gibt es neue strömungen
die sich als neo materialistische
strömungen bezeichnen lassen wo
körperlichkeit sinnlichkeit unser
verständnis von uns selber als
materielle wesen ganz wichtig werden
dieses spannende handel der philosoph
tim in den berliner berlin lehrt der
spricht auch von der ästhetik das
klapphandy eben dieser ganzen digitalen
produkte uns eigentlich so dir was haben
das uns abweist und ich glaube darauf
deuten sie auch an
ich möchte noch von herrn so beschließen
sie sind ja tibetologen wie sind sie
denn das erste mal mit hunter in
berührung gekommen oder ja
was haben sie für einen bezug dazu ich
habe tatsächlich schon in meiner frühen
jugend mich sehr interessiert für tibet
und indien habe alle möglichen bücher
verschlungen dazu und hab dann in
hamburg die biologie indologie und
philosophie studiert hauptsächlich
tibetologie und auch in meiner
studienzeit schon viele
studienaufenthalte in indien in ladakh
und nepal gehabt und habe dann in der
zeit vor allen dingen spezialisiert bis
heute hin eigentlich auf die
überlieferung der tantrischen tradition
von indien nach tibet und die praxis der
tantra in tibet und vor allen dingen
habe ich mich auch beschäftigt mit der
frage wie tantra von den tibetern in den
buddhismus integriert wird und in diesem
zusammenhang habe ich eben auch selber
viele sehr interessante begegnungen
gehabt sehr enge arbeitskontakte auch
gehabt mit tantrischen praktizierenden
in nepal und ladakh und indien darüber
erzählen sie uns hoffentlich dann auch
während des gespräches jetzt hat ja mein
kollege im vorfeld die tantra lehrerin
und autorin da jener richardson
getroffen sie kommt ursprünglich aus
südafrika sie gilt als eine koryphäe
unter den tantra meistern und bietet im
emmental zusammen mit ihrem partner
tantra kurse an
ja wir sitzen hier in einem
wunderschönen raum was ist das wozu
brauchen sie diesen raum
das ist der domkuppel ein wunderschöner
raum und eine der waldhaus seminarräume
dank seiner kuppel hat er sehr spezielle
schwingungen unsere seminare führen wir
aber in einem gebäude auf der anderen
straßenseite in der haupthalle durch sie
geben ja kurse für paare im liebe machen
eine woche lang sind die dann hier muss
ich mir das vorstellen rennt man da dax
durch die gegend und fasst sich
gegenseitig nein so ist es nicht jedes
bleibt beim festen partner es gibt im
gruppenraum keinen partnertausch und
auch keine nacktheit oder 6 das
geschieht in der privatheit des zimmers
im chores kombinieren wir tanzübungen
und körperarbeit in dem täglichen
gesprächen mit den paaren geben wir
ihnen anleitungen zum liebe machen die
sie in den freien zeiten am nachmittag
ausprobieren können
es läuft alles sehr professionell ab ja
seit knapp 30 jahren geben sie kurse für
besseren sex habe viele bücher
geschrieben über tantra was würden sie
sagen ist die grundidee von tantra
contra einem begriff aus dem alt
indischen sanskrit geht es um wach sein
um achtsamkeit um
bewusstseinserweiterung wir empfinden
unsere körperlichkeit ganz besonders
beim sex meist als ein innen wie wir ihn
kennen ist voller spannung was uns eben
oft einschnürt eigentlich wäre unser
körper ja dafür gemacht energie
freizusetzen
dazu müssten wir aber ganz gegenwärtig
seien in unserem körper
üblicherweise dreht sich beim sex albums
kommen um zum ziel zu kommen
anders im tantris muss hier gilt es
dinge bewusst wahrzunehmen
diese achtsamkeit verlangsamt alles man
spürt viel mehr die sensibilität erhöht
sich damit wechselt die perspektive
das kann sehr wertvoll sein insbesondere
im geschäftigen alltag mit all seinen
belastung des kinder- oder die arbeit
wodurch paare auf die verbindung
zueinander verlieren in der woche die
sie hier verbringen widmen sie sich ganz
der liebesbeziehung zusammen in der
gruppe versuchen wir über tanz oder
qigong die achtsamkeit zu fördern
das erstreckt sich auf die privaten
liebe sitzungen wo es darum geht das
körperbewusstsein zu stärken
sie unterscheidet zwei arten von sechs
heißen sex auf der einen seite und
kühlen 6 auf die andere seite und sie
plädiere er für den kühlen 6 was muss
ich mir darunter verstehen die meisten
menschen kennen heißen sex das ist es
was man normalerweise unter sechs
versteht temperatur intensität und das
empfinden steigern sich bis zum
überlaufen
zur explosion zu einer ejakulation viele
männer kennen das problem zu früh zu
kommen
sie werden dadurch verunsichert und
beginnen an sie selbst und ihrer
männlichkeit zu zweifeln vorzeitige
ejakulation sind auch für die partnerin
schwierig wenn sie unbefriedigt bleibt
das kann zu sekundären psychologischen
probleme wie angst oder eben selbst
reifen führen oder dazu den sechs aus
einer vermeidungs haltung gleich ganz
wegzulassen
der eigentliche grund für den
frühzeitigen samenerguss liegt aber
darin dass wir zu heiß werden im 6 eine
frühzeitige ejakulation kurz dem
geschlecht sagt ab so bleibt oft nicht
genug zeit damit sich etwas zwischen den
kassen entwickeln und entfalten kann
grundsätzlich ja wir unterliegen dem
treffen missverständnis dass es beim sex
einzig und im höhepunkt geht natürlich
ist er herrlich und wundervoll
beim genauen hinschauen zeigt sich aber
dass ich nachher oft ein gefühl der
trennung einstellt auf die innere
verbundenheit folgt der orgasmus und
dann nichts deshalb auch die witze über
schnarchen der männer und weinende
frauen tatsächlich entsteht oft ein
verlust gefühl ich sage nicht dass
dieser ansatz falsch ist aber er hat
auswirkungen auf der liebesbeziehung
wenn man das liebesspiel aus lienen kann
und die im tantrischen sinn nicht auf
dem gipfel gestürmt
soll man das locker nimmt ein bisschen
indiskrete fragen darf wenn sie mit
ihrem partner sex haben ich möchte das
nicht vertiefen um nicht erwartungen zu
wecken
aber es kann durchaus sein dass drei bis
zwölf stunden hat und an sicher nicht
jeden tag wer hätte dafür zeit
reaktion oder ist das gar nicht schlimm
wenn es das auch nicht gibt es trotzdem
denn die körper wirklich miteinander
verbunden sind bleibt die reaktion der
energie oft bestehe gewöhnlicher sex
lebt von der erregung der stimulation
zur reaktion ist nun aber wirklich
miteinander im augenblick in der liebe
verbunden bleibt die reaktion falls
nicht kann man auch mit einem
entspannten penis liebe machen
wir zeigen den paaren wie das geht
natürlich tun wir das nicht live sondern
demonstrieren es über den kleidern
das ist ein weiteres problem dass meine
oft haben die last eine erektion haben
zu müssen
liebe machen aber gehörenden liebe und
sexualität immer zusammen oder kann ich
auch an trischen sex haben mit jemandem
den ich nicht liebe das ist gar keine
leichte frage für die meisten von uns
geschieht sex ohne viel liebe man
benutzt einander ohne dass viel liebe im
spiel ist
wenn wir uns aber achtsam reinbringen
erzeugen wir lieber meist läuft das ja
so ab am anfang einer partnerschaft hat
man viel heißen sex dann flaut das
interesse allmählich ab das ist der
klassische verlauf man entfremdet sich
und verliert die verbindung zu einer
durch das eintauchen in den körper kann
man die verbindung wieder herstellen
ganz am anfang der beziehung oder mit
einem anderen partner ist die sexuelle
erfahrung auf gut
das hat viel mit wachheit zu tun mit
einem fremden ist man meist ganz präsent
am anfang einer beziehung ist man meist
ganz dabei dann gewöhnt man sich
aneinander und driftet langsam ab alles
hängt von dieser wachheit ab sie schafft
die liebe und die verbindung interessant
also diese 18
das ganz bei sich sein ist sehr zentral
aber es gibt da bei bei der erotik in
der sexualität auch diese momente wo wir
total aus und sind diese ekstatischen
momente das stimmt zwar aber meine
erfahrung ist eine andere
wir unterrichten dass man eintauchen
muss um aus sich herauszukommen
da geht doch diesen song wenn wir in den
körper eintauchen und uns auf diese
ebene sinnlich vereinen breitet sich die
energie aus körperliche grenzen lösen
sich auf man fühlt sich nicht mehr
abgespalten sondern eins mit dem ganzen
universum
es ist schön bereichernd und erhebend
diese spirituelle erfahrung vergisst man
nie mehr
also man ein gefühl des einst werdens
mit mit dem ganzen diese unio mystica
ter stegen mystische idee also ist
sozusagen die sexualität der weg zu
dieser erweiterung dass ich oder zu
diesem auflösender grenzen genau dieses
1 werden wird ja auch in vielen
verschiedenen religionen
wird beim tantra oder genauer beim niro
tantra denn das sexuelle elemente
entstand erst vor 1500 oder 2000 jahren
nutzt man ganz konkret die sexuelle
situation um zur achtsamkeit zu gelangen
die körperliche verbindung über den
penis und die vagina sich berührenden
lippen ermöglichen diese wahrheit auf
die schönste art es ist eine der
einfachsten möglichkeiten diese
bewusstseinserweiterung zu erfahren
eine figur die sie stark geprägt hat war
der indische musik und philosophie show
auch backwaren genannt der in den 70er
jahren in indien in pune ein azra mann
zentrum gegründet hat sie waren auch bei
ihm 1979 jetzt ist diese figur aber sehr
umstritten also es gibt vorwürfe wegen
missbrauch wegen drogenkonsum im ashram
dann gibt es auch von otto selbst
haarsträubende aussagen zu
homosexualität und zu behinderten
wie gehen sie mit dieser kritik um alles
was ich weiß ist dass ich ohne diese
erfahrung nicht hier sitzen und mit
ihnen sprechen würde
ich habe unendlich viel von dieser
person gelernt die erfahrung hat mich
persönlich sehr bereichert und mir
geholfen die welt und die psychologie zu
ergründen und mit menschen zu arbeiten
er ist als person sehr umstritten
um menschen die die dinge anders angehen
entstehen immer kontroversen
ob es da oder missbrauchen ashram gab
sicher nicht mehr meinen freunden und
sicher nicht bei mir
wie lange waren sie da ich lebte
insgesamt zwölf jahre lang an diesem
großartigen ort dazu über die gegenwart
dieses unglaublichen meisters er hat
eine solche ausstrahlung aber auch
indien selbst ist fantastisch das land
stellt uns völlig auf den kopf
in indien sieht man die dinge ganz
anders als hier im westen
für uns ist alles linear dort ist alles
sehr viel mehr im fluss indien war
großartig
es hat sich seitdem vieles verändert
gerade auch durch die
bevölkerungszunahme ja die idee von
tantra kommt die ursprünglich aus indien
und da waren zwei religionen sehr
wichtig sieht der hinduismus und
buddhismus rolle spielten die religion
in der form wie sie traf verstehen heute
und praktizieren ich bin keine
intellektuelle ich setze mich mit meinem
körper auseinander wie bereits gesagt
praktiziere ich neo tantra sex als ein
canal genutzt wird
bei den anderen religionen geht es um
liebevolle güte wachsamkeit und
achtsamkeit
ich befasse mich nicht aktiv damit aber
was ich lehre nährt sich aus diesen
wurzeln sondern eher im körper und ja so
ist es
[Musik]
die vorstellung dass es da draußen etwas
gibt fällt den menschen leicht die
realität aber beginnt hier mit unserem
hoch entwickelten denken ging die
verbindungen zum gehirn hinterkopf
unserem alten gehirn verloren wo es mehr
um die sinne und die sinnlichkeit ging
wir sind heute abgespalten von diesem
körper der doch die brücke zu hören
erfahrungen darstellt und nicht nur der
körper sondern der älteste teil unseres
gehirns vielleicht bringt uns dazu dass
wir diese bewusstseinserweiterung mehr
war halt in 6 führt zu mehr war halt im
alltag und eine bewusste gestaltung des
alltags führt auch zu bewussterem sex
das sind keine getrennten bereiche aus
eigener erfahrung und von den
erzählungen vieler paare weiß ich dass
sehr viele dinge im leben dadurch anders
werden
es ist alles plötzlich mehr im fluss die
art wie man arbeitet wie man die teller
recht wie man kocht gerne mit vielen
herzlichen dank
es war schön mit ihm zu sprechen ja wir
haben es gerade gehört mehr bewusstheit
in der sexualität mehr bewusstheit im
alltag frau mag waschen sie ihr geschirr
wie sie gesagt hat auch anders ab nachts
antrag natürlich nicht immer aber das
ist natürlich schon auch einen dieser
hauptelemente dass das das ganze leben
bewusster gestaltet werden kann und da
habe ich schon auch meine rituale im
alltag dass ich zum beispiel morgens an
tanze oder yoga mache ein bisschen
meditieren oder mir auch den tag nach
maß bewusst vor augen führe vor dem
einschlafen aber nie das gelingt wenn
ich immer erklären sie mal sie sind ja
eben kann passieren und wie läuft denn
eine solche massage ob sie haben ja auch
zwei elemente die darin vorkommen
mitgenommen erzählen sie mal ganz
wichtig ist das vorgespräch wo ich mit
der kärnten oder den kärnten abklären
was ist denn eigentlich das bedürfnis
dass es die motivation für diese massage
was ist auch die vorstellung von tantra
und auch hier dann diese abgrenzung
machen zu können
was ist es und was ist es nicht das er
dass es zum beispiel nicht einfach eine
bedürfnisbefriedigung ist und ein happy
end in happy ends massage sondern dass
es absichtslos ist dass zwar der
intimbereich mit angezogen wird jedes
andere körperteile auch aber dass es
nicht um eine einfach lustbefriedigung
per se geht und dann auch ob seine
intension gibt es gibt menschen die
kommen mit ganz verschiedenen
hintergründen in diese massage und dann
geht es eigentlich ins eröffnungsrede wo
es zuerst einmal darum geht bei sich
selbst anzukommen hinein zu spielen wo
stehe ich gerade meinen emotionen mit
meinen gedanken aber auch wie fühlt sich
mein körper grad an bevor wir dann
zusammen in eine verbindung gehen und
diese massage dann eröffnen und dann
wird die person einen 23 stunden lang
verwöhnt mit allen sinnen und war so
genau von dieser lösung wie zum beispiel
im spiel tantris auch ganz wichtig oder
für mich dass wir diese auf augenhöhe
cent betragen also beide diesen jungi zu
beginn und zum ende und sonst ist man
merkt während der massage
ich bin nackt oder in unterhose je
nachdem wie ich mich kratzt will damit
und dann kann man zum beispiel den look
ja auch benutzen um die person dann auch
ein bisschen noch zu streichen damit und
dieser diese klangschale um das ritual
zu eröffnen und am schluss auch wieder
zu schließen das ist wichtig dass es wie
sein
ein klares einen klaren beginn hat und
ein klares ende und nach der massage
gibt es auch wieder anschluss gespräch
wo wir einpacken miteinander wie war
diese reise und ja das ist so ganz grob
der ablauf und weshalb müssen sie dafür
nackt sein um diese massage zu machen
weil es eben auch genau darum geht es
keinen schambereich mehr gibt dass wir
das es nicht eben ein körperteil gibt
der das schmutzig oder scham behaftet
ist sondern
dass wir beide uns in unserer folgen
wesensart zeigen und und wir in dem
sinne auch gleichgestellt sind
aber es geht nicht darum das erklären
zum beispiel zurück berührt also die
rollenverteilung ist klar ich bin die
gebende und die andere person darf da
liegen und empfangen was auch für viele
ein großes learning ist weil wir in der
sexualität ja sehr oft in dieser dynamik
sind von a das war schön jetzt will ich
dir was zurückgeben
und es geht auch nicht primär darum eine
stimulation zu bieten jetzt visuell dass
ich nackt bin sondern es geht wirklich
einfach darum dass er
und so zeigen wie wir sind sie haben
jetzt aber auch gesagt was ganz wichtig
ist dass es ist nicht zielgerichtet es
soll nicht obwohl die geschlechtsteile
auch mit massiert werden es auch nicht
auf einen orgasmus zählen einzelne
menschen haben natürlich trotzdem einen
orgasmus haben mir gesagt in etwa 30
prozent egal ob frauen oder männer da
ich frage mich trotzdem genau wenn es
eben nicht darum geht was suchen die
menschen jetzt vielleicht auch angedockt
an das was die frau denn er schaut zuvor
gesagt hat eingangs ja es gibt menschen
die kommen aus neugierde die wissen oder
merken dass sexualität oder auch
spiritualität noch mehr umfassen kann
dass das was sie in ihrem privatleben
schon erlebt haben oder eben auch in
diesen dynamischen wo es ja auch immer
einen gewissen stressfaktor gibt also
wenn ich ihn in eine intime beziehung
mit jemandem dann ist auch immer eine
erwartungshaltung dahinter da ist
vielleicht ein druck da ich hab zu
performen ich hab was zu leisten zu
geben oder zu sein und das in einem
rahmen erleben zu dürfen wo das alles
wegfällt weil ich habe dann keine
erwartung der muss federn orgasmus noch
eine erektion noch sonst irgendwas
geschehen in dieser massage ich begleite
die person dahin wo sie geht und ich
glaube dass es ein großer motivator es
geht aber auch menschen die kommen mit
mit einer geschichte
die vielleicht auch dramatisch war und
die spielen dass sie mehr haben sich
wieder einlassen zu können auf andere
menschen sexuell und die möchten das
gerne in einem sicheren rahmen wieder
leben dort ist es eine form von fast
schon körpertherapie daneben
ja das kann auch dahin gehen auch wenn
es da nicht so ein bewusster oder
ausgesprochene prozesse ist aber ja
wirklich einfach jetzt ist ja aber auch
so dass es rechtlich gesehen eigentlich
sex arbeit ist oder was sie anbieten
und ich frage mich dann ist das eben
eine erotische spirituelle erfahrung die
man sich kaufen kann
ja also ist fällt und der sexarbeit
rechtlich gesehen und trotzdem ist es
für mich das nicht weil es ist ja eben
nicht eine bedürfnisbefriedigung also
ich gebe keine orgasmus garantie ab und
trotzdem genau gibt es natürlich auch
menschen die die das suchen so und die
zum teil noch erstaunt sind weil tantra
dieser begriff auch sehr weit gebraucht
wird in der gesellschaft es gibt auch
angebote wo das wie mit drinnen ist
aber so wie ich tantra verstehe und
anbietet und lebe in diesem sinne ist
das nicht mit dabei frau werner scheint
eben diese ziellosigkeit es geht nicht
um orgasmus fixierung ist das eine form
von belohnungs aufschub ich weiß nicht
genau also die frage ist was dann
ob es am ende eine belohnung gibt ob
dann die spirituelle erfahrungen das
gefühl von erlös sein sich hingeben
können wenn das als belohnung verstanden
wird also ich kann mir vorstellen dass
der dass der begriff der belohnung gar
nicht passen und ist weil wir dann
gleich in seinem ökonomischen denkens
sind was bekomme ich was gäbe ich also
dass das macht sinn dass dieses tauschs
denken dabei eigentlich aufgehoben wird
ich weiß nicht ob es vielleicht dass es
so was wie eine sub linierung also da
wird jetzt sexualität eigentlich fast
alles was problematisches gesehen was
was irgendwie zurückgenommen werden muss
also ich habe das noch nicht ganz
verstanden wie also wo denn wo das also
ob die ziellosigkeit denn gleichzeitig
doch wieder ein ziel das hinterher
worauf sie sinniert oder also mir wäre
der gedanke angenehmer wenn man dieses
teleologische denken also das denkt sie
hinauf ein ziel tatsächlich aufgeben
könnte und so wie sie ist es gerade
beschrieben haben klingt mir das
eigentlich eher so insofern hatte ich
jetzt nicht das gefühl dass es um einen
ein belohnungs aufschub geht aber die
frage wäre für mich schon also welche
rolle das spiel tatsächlich sexualität
dabei also weil die sexualität so wie
ich es verstehen wird also wir können
natürlich auch lust mit uns selber haben
so wenn wir an an ist ische praktiken
denken muss ja auch so wunderbar ist
aber also sexualität würde ich
tatsächlich ja eher als etwas verstehen
was sich zwischen menschen
konventioneller weise zwischen zwei
menschen muss ja aber nicht sein also
kann man den kreis ja auch erweitert
denken also welche rolle sexualität
wirklich da in diesem in dieser
tantrischen begegnung spielt ich möchte
das gerne noch theoretisch einordnen und
dafür so beschreiben diese punkte die
wir jetzt gerade erörtert haben und
überhaupt diese form von tantra die frau
wenn die frauen mag und die fritten im
einspieler ja neo tantra genannt haben
die geht er zurück auf die figur show wo
eben so was wie bewusstheit intern eben
also bewusstheit in der sexualität der
kern davon ist so hat im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert in den usa und in indien
gewirkt ich habe mich gefragt der
begriff tantra der da eben auch noch
verwendet wird ist trifft es schrecklich
zu oder ist es auch irgendwas
marketingmäßig es wie würden sie das
beschreiben
dazu muss man schon ein bisschen auf
ausholen frau richardson ist tatsächlich
so wie sie sich ausdrückt ein sehr enge
anhängerin von backwaren das kann man an
den einzelnen aussagen hören sie hat ihn
teilweise sogar zitiert aus seinen
büchern
dazu muss man verstehen dass backwaren
eine person war die zu einer gruppe von
gurus gehörte die auch aktivisten waren
insofern als dass sie ein echo
fabriziert haben auf die koloniale
kritik der indischen religion und
speziell des tantra dazu gehört zum
beispiel weg wie wir einander der auch
eine art von tantra gelehrt hat aber da
schon all die unappetitlichen seiten des
indischen tantra völlig überdeckt hat
und welche genommen hat das hat
backwaren eben auch getan er hat eben
halt auch sie eine eine sehr bereinigte
vorne ist tantra gelehrt dazu gehört
auch wenn du der genauso wie backwaren
eben auch eigentlich überhaupt kein
lehrer hatte sondern sich seine form der
praxis gelehrt hat aus büchern
zusammengesucht hat und einzelne
elemente hier und dort übernommen hat
teilweise die elemente auch komplett ins
gegenteil verkehrt hat das hat backwaren
auch getan
ja zum beispiel hatte diese diese
ekstatische tänze und schütteln lachen
und so weiter die dann hinzu
ritualisierten sex führen können
auch aus indischen scheiber tantra übung
übernommen plus dort wird es viel viel
weiter geführt dort wird es also
orgiastisch ekstatisch mit einer
gehörigen steigerung der sinneserfahrung
oder er hat auch diese asketischen
übungen er aus dem osmanischen yoga
übernommen
obwohl er eigentlich diese praxis
eher als repressiv abgelehnt hat also es
geht aus aus eigentlich im grunde
genommen eine sehr alte pragmatische
yoga praxis zurück wo selbst ehepaare
zusammen im zölibat leben
sie haben zwar körperlichen kontakt sie
haben auch sexuellen kontakt aber sie
haben eben kein chaos und kein vor allem
keine evakuation der mann hat keine
regulation das ist eine asketische
selbstbeherrschung praxis die dann auch
von einem schäfer tantra weitergeführt
wurde mit kreuzes aber immer noch ohne
evakuation dort aber dann auch eben
ekstatisch weitergeführt und im
zusammenhang mit drogen genuss und sehr
übersteigerter sinneserfahrung ja das
ziel was die was was was formuliert
wurde auch von frau richardson ist ja
auch offensichtlich sehr schwammig ja es
ist ein bisschen auflösung der
persönlichkeit es ist ein bisschen ein
dualismus ist es ist ein bisschen tower
genannt worden
das ist wahrscheinlich auch so gewollt
denn dies bietet natürlich auch raum für
die projektion der westlichen anhänger
denn das muss man einfach verstehen
diese diese form des tantra des neo
tantra ist ein angebot das ist eine
rückkopplung aus der aus der kolonialen
kritik und es ist dann ein angebot das
also sehr stark informiert wird auch
durch die wünsche und projektion
westlicher menschen
insofern kann man sagen also
insbesondere backwaren hat die kommune
modifizierung und kommerzialisierung der
indischen religionen schon sehr weit
getrieben hat so bestimmen da müssen wir
jetzt natürlich eben das traditionelle
klären also die tantrische philosophie
ist schätzungsweise 2000 jahre alt dann
gibt es eben diese us kritischen
elemente drin
gleichzeitig sprechen wir hier von
sexualität der dalai lama ist selber
auch centrica inszeniert sich hier auch
hierzulande auch als zölibat ihr also
was ist denn jetzt tantra
das wird nicht so leicht zu klären sein
dass es gibt sehr viele verschiedene
formen von tantra man könnte vielleicht
etwas weiter ansetzen und sagen es gibt
in indien
sowohl diese ekstatischen wilden form
der religionsausübung die auch sehr viel
zu tun haben mit unreinen substanzen mit
reinen substanzen und so weiter mit dem
mit der magie die aus den unreinen
substanzen gewonnen werden kann und mit
der reinigung die aus den reinen
substanzen gewonnen werden kann aber es
gibt eben auch als gegensatz dazu immer
die brach manischen yogischen
asketischen übung diese diese diese
spannung gibt es in indien immer und die
gibt es auch im tantra und was sind denn
reine und unreine substanzen zb jainta
nimmt antreibe zum beispiel wenn sie von
den ältesten ursprüngen des indischen
hinduistischen tantra sprechen die sie
haben wir eben diese sehr alten zwei
zurückgehenden tantra praktischen
praktiken erwähnt wenn sie davon
sprechen dann kommt das eigentlich aus
einem fruchtbarkeits kult niveau zurück
geht auf eine mutter göttin und hier
wurde eine idee entwickelt dass das blut
der mutter geld in das menstruationsblut
eine fruchtbarkeit für das land bedeutet
es dass die der menstruationszyklus der
mutter göttin wurde mit den vegetations
zyklus und den fruchtbarkeits zyklus des
landes korreliert und da eben alle
frauen in gewisser weise mütter sein
können zumindest ein potenzial dafür
haben wurde dann eben auch die kraft und
macht dieser dieses blutes oder dieser
dieser substanz die in der mutter
göttinnen drin ist auch auf die frauen
übertragen und so wurden dann die idee
vielleicht die früheste zu den frühesten
ritualen gehörte es eben an diese
substanz die in der frau ist die der
mann nicht hat und an die der mann heran
kommen möchte zu kommen zb indem es
zunächst einmal eben dass das
menstruationsblut verwendet wurde
das verlangte dann nach einer nach einer
gegengabe nach einer rituellen geben
gabe die bestandteile aus dem männlichen
samen und aus der vermischung dieser
beiden substanzen entstand eben eine
neue substanz die auf der einen seite
die fruchtbarkeit symbolisierte also was
sehr positives war auf der anderen seite
aber auch alle tabus beinhaltete die die
vedische religion eigentlich hatte und
durch dieses tabu entsteht natürlich
diese diese diese magische spannung und
diese möglichkeit aus diesen substanzen
heraus sich magische kräfte aneignen zu
können letztendlich geht es in dieser
praxis eben wo es später wurde auch eben
durch sexuelle stimulation dann scheiden
flüssigkeit dazu genommen
letztendlich geht es in dieser art von
frühen tantra darum sich magische kräfte
anzueignen fliegen zu können
herrschaft zu haben über über frauen
über junge mädchen und so weiter also
etwas es geht um
es geht um rein um unrein es geht aber
auch um eine form der revolution eben
gegen eine form der orthodoxen religion
es geht um eine rituelle auflösung von
von qualitäten aufhebung von kasten und
geschlechterunterschiede werner scheid
ja das sind nicht ganz spannend dass er
das auf der einen seite wird viel davon
gesprochen dass eben dualität aufgehoben
werden oder grenzen porös werden aber
mir scheint das nicht ganz der fall zu
sein also wenn wenn herrschaft doch
immer erhalten bleibt also das kann ja
nur funktionieren wenn es doch irgendwie
wenn es ein festhalten an männlichen und
weiblichen pole und irgendwie gibt die
zwar miteinander in berührung kommen
vielleicht sogar auch verschmelzen
sollen aber dieses binäre denken bleibt
eigentlich ja doch erhalten also neuere
geschlechter und körper theorien würden
damit nicht glücklich werden also da da
ist ja eher das interesse wirklich
dieses auf dieses dieses begriffliche
aufzulösen als wenn
in binären kategorien denken dass es das
eben gar nicht mehr gibt
ja hat denn diese religiöse beck an den
wir gerade ausgeführt wirkungen haben
für sie und für ihre praxis irgendwie
eine relevanz oder wie beziehen sie sich
darauf ich würde es nicht als religiös
bezeichnen aber dass der mindset
dahinter und das ist für mich die die
achtsamkeit die präsenz dass sein mit
dem was ist und aber auch wie sie sagen
dieses auflösen von männlich und
weiblich nämlich dass das ich mir
bewusst bin und dass ich auch meinem
gegenüber oder dass wir uns bewusst
werden dass wir beides in uns tragen das
weil ich wie das nämliche egal ob jetzt
in einem weiblichen oder männlichen
körper sind das sind für mich elemente
die sehr wohl rein spielen in die tonne
massage aber interessanterweise also das
männliche und das weibliche auch wenn
sie sagen es gibt es in also in zu
gleichen anteilen oder zu gemischten
anteilen in jeder person also warum dann
überhaupt noch von männlichen und anteil
männlichen und weiblichen anteilen
sprechen also ist das bleibt man da
nicht eben doch so in diesem denken also
es hat ja auch den viel mit passiv und
aktiv zu tun also warum warum wird das
wort während männlich und weiblich
genannt wie er oder zugespitzt
formuliert ist es stellt sich daher die
frage ist das nicht eine konservative
form also welche welchem platz
hackenberg nonnen binäre personen oder
andere andere geschlecht sexueller
orientierungen
also ich glaube ja das ist so es ist
wahrscheinlich einfach ein
erklärungsmodell an das einfacher für
menschen ins zu verstehen
aber auch in indien ich war auf den
indien reisen
und da wird das ja auch tatsächlich
gelebt also zum beispiel gibt es da auch
viele männer die sich als frauen kleiden
oder einfach auch ausbrechen aus diesen
männlichen weiblichen fusions druckten
genau und da bin ich jetzt zum beispiel
völlig offen dafür
das ist auch immer ein teil des
vorbereitungs gespräches auf eine
massage
diese frage nach du bist jetzt
vielleicht einen in einem weiblichen
körper aber wie fühlst du dich dann zum
beispiel identifiziert du dich auch als
eine frau oder was ist eine sexuelle
orientierung das muss ja nicht
ausschlaggebend sein aber das zeigt
trotzdem die offenheit dafür für dieses
thema werden zuvor noch von diesen
überschreitungen also von diesem
transgression auch das ganz zentral ist
für uns herr so bisher erläutert hat für
diese diese strömung des tourismus und
bis heute sieht man in varanasi der
einer der heiligen stadt denning gehen
all kand rische asketen die sich eben um
leichen verbrennungs plätze herum
tummeln wir schauen kurz rein in den
straßen sitzen solche sogenannten babas
selbsternannte gottesmänner aller art
und offerieren ihre vermeintlich
magischen kräfte ich bin ein country
aber wenn du ein problem hast wenn du
unerfüllte regierten und wünsche hast
ein gebet das nicht erhört wurde dann
noch ihrem eine mobiltelefonnummer und
ruf mich an ich bin nicht hungrig nach
macht oder zauberei wenn du mir glaubst
kannst du mir etwas geld wieder
sonst gehe des weges tantra ist der
triumph des guten über das böse
wir leben in finsteren zeiten einer zeit
des niedergangs mütter werden nicht mehr
wie mütter behandelt und schwestern und
töchter werden nicht verschont
aber ich bin ein abstinent tabara schaue
nur diese kette ich trage sie immer um
meine hüfte ich habe mich verpflichtet
sind niemals zu öffnen wenn ich es doch
täten würden alle meine zauberkräfte
verschwinden ich kann die kette nicht
öffnen
niemals
ich ernähre mich nur von alkohol und
fleisch wenn ich nichts zu fressen
finden gehe ich zu den kremation plätzen
und nehme mir ein stück fleisch von den
leichen und trinke alkohol dazu ich
brauche weiter nichts für streng
gläubige hindus gilt es als besonders
erstrebenswert in varanasi zu sterben
und dort prämiert zu werden
direkt am fluss werden die leichen
verbrannt dort halten sich viele der
tantrischen babas auf um ihre finsteren
rituale durchzuführen leichenschändung
würde man dazu außerhalb indiens sagen
naja sobisch weshalb braucht es denn
diese radikalen tabubrüche auf dem weg
zur erleuchtung ja zunächst mal sehen
sie das hat eben einfach mit sexualität
nichts zu tun in diesem fall diese
auflösung von dualität wird hier ganz
anders gelebt also ist das 1 1 eine eine
sehr oft die sinne ausgerichtete praxis
in diesem fall die agora yogis ja die
sehen eben sämtliche einteilung von rein
und unrein als juristische projektion
die es zu überwinden gilt und wie wird
das überwunden das wird nicht durch
sexualität oder durch sexuelle praxis
überwunden sondern es wird durch diese
diese leichen platz symbolik die
verbrennungs platz symbolik überwunden
dass diese yogis sich mit knochen mit
menschlichen knochen schmücken dass die
kleidung von von vom gleichen platz
aufsammeln und tragen dass die
schädelschalen von verstorbenen als
getränkebecher verwenden und so weiter
und auch gegebenenfalls auch menschen
fleisch essen das ist eben eine reine
ein transkript verhalten das überaus
stark gesteigert ist so stark gesteigert
wird das eben aus dieser übersteigerung
des das des unappetitlichen des
widerwärtigen geradezu eben die das
sollte letztendlich zur auflösung der
dualität führen in der erfahrung der
dieser yogis und dieses überschreiben
werden dieses trans kreative auch das
brechen von tabus mir es gerade gehört
haben also aus schädeln bringt man so
weit dass er auch etwas das sie
beschäftigt ja dass ich finde es
wirklich sehr interessant weil das ja
also in der die christliche religion ist
ja eher eine religion der reinheit würde
ich sagen aber das hat natürlich auch
einzelne denker philosophen autoren
autorinnen
dazu veranlasst mit dieser reinheit
radikal zu brechen also wenn wir an den
französischen philosophen der fünfziger
jahre denken und georges partei der
gerade das verfemte oder wie giulia
christe war auch eine französische
philosophin sagen würde dass objekte
also das was wir aus sondern mit dem wir
nicht
zu tun haben wollen dass wir von uns weg
halten was wir aus grenzen dass das
wieder reingeholt werden soll in die
dann aber doch wieder ganz explizit in
die in die sexuelle erfahrung also da da
sehe ich also dass sich dieses interesse
an dem transgression was es eben auch im
westlichen denken gibt sicherlich gibt
es da aber auch starke anleihen in der
indischen religionen oder in den
indischen tradition also gerade auch was
bestimmte form von ritualen angeht also
natürlich kennen wir auch in der
christlichen religion rituale aber die
sind nicht so nicht so körper bezogen
aber beide parteien zb spielen diese
rituale auch nur eine große rolle dass
bestimmte bereiche die wir mit schmutz
in verbindung bringen im kot und blut
also dass das jetzt auf einmal
tatsächlich wieder was sein soll was wir
auch mit in unsere körpererfahrung
einnehmen
und da spielt das tabu da spielt das
verbot das spielt die grenze eine
wichtige rolle
die grenzen die überschritten werden
muss und wo die lust im augenblick der
überschreitung ins spiel kommt also das
so ja weshalb ist das so weil es eine
eine sehnsucht nach ekstatischem erleben
gibt also wo auch das selbst nicht mehr
der kontrolle der vernunft unterworfen
ist wo es ein bedürfnis oder ein wunsch
gibt nach anderen erfahrungen von in der
welt sein also partei er sagt das dass
wir eigentlich in einer
diskontinuierlichen welt leben also
alles ist abgepackt in kleine einzelne
häppchen sozusagen
wir betrachten das alles rational und
verloren das in so einem strom in so
einem absoluten umfassenden sinne zu
erleben und da ist für ihn sexualität
eine möglichkeit da wieder reinzukommen
und auch ja dass das vernunft bestimmte
subjekt hinter uns zu lassen und das
wiederum ist auch etwas was wir in
neueren philosophischen strömungen die
sich dem neu materialismus zuordnen
finden also dass das subjekt in den
hintergrund rückt das hat aber jetzt da
ganz andere kontexte mich eher
umweltbewusste kontext also auch nicht
wissen darum dass wir mit unserem
westlichen denken dass ich dass wir da
viel schaden angerichtet haben in
unserer welt in unserer natur und der
versuch dieses ich wieder zurück zu
nehmen und uns zu verstehen als als eine
entität eine größe die eingebunden ist
in ganz viele miteinander verflochtene
zusammenhänge
also das ist das was glaube ich auch im
moment wieder gerade im bewusstsein von
klimakrise und anderen katastrophen ganz
wichtig wurde sodass gesehen wird dass
das dass das westliche selbstverständnis
dass das zu einem problematischen
herrschaftsanspruch geführt hat und
diese herrschaftsanspruch hat viel viel
schlechtes bewirkt und deswegen gibt es
eine art weg bewegung dieser herrschaft
das ist ja spannend mich interessiert
aber noch dieses ekstatische was jetzt
auch erwähnt hat und die starke
körperlichkeit
das ist ja die körperlichkeit ist
offensichtlich jetzt frage ich bei ihnen
wie wie zentral das ist doch das
ekstatische ein element dass sie damit
am streben angestrebte das nicht weil es
soll ja zielen und absichtslos sein aber
es ist sehr willkommen ich glaube ein
großer faktor dabei ist die die atmung
zum beispiel aber auch diese unrein
elemente die sie eben genannt haben zb
blut oder kot aber was jetzt in einer
tram massage natürlich nicht eben gegend
zentrales element ist aber wenn es dann
vorbei hin oder vivo hat das anstellen
wird hier zum beispiel jetzt frauen die
gerade ihre tage haben und sagen hey
jetzt sind sie doch ein bisschen freier
gekommen als gedacht darf ich trotzdem
kommen und dass es dann ist ja sehr
gerne das ist willkommen dein blut ist
nicht einfach jetzt schmutzig du musst
dich nicht dafür schämen
du darfst auch so da sein oder auch
menschen die lust haben in ihren
analbereich zu entdecken und das für sie
aber auch immer noch scham behaftet ist
zu einem gott was ist denn wenn wir doch
noch ein bisschen was rauskommt oder so
und und da einfach in eine entspanntheit
zu kommen zu spielen das ist alles
willkommen es ist teil unserer
menschlichkeit und das hat jetzt nicht
wirklich etwas mit ekstase zu tun und
trotzdem ist es glaube ich eine
befreiung und durch diese befreiung ist
der weg vielleicht auch in eine andere
bewusstseinsebene erleichterung dieser
andere bewusstseinsebene würden sie das
als erleuchtung bezeichnen oder ist das
ein weg dorthin oder wie geht da der
begriff erleuchtung rein also so wie ich
die die tantrische philosophie verstehe
ist das schon auch das ziel also die
energie die jetzt zum beispiel durch
eine sexuelle stimulation erlangt wird
im becken dieser energie zu sublimieren
das heißt durch den körper zu ziehen und
nicht einfach über einen orgasmus hinaus
zu lassen sondern das wirklich so durch
alle schatten zu ziehen und dann in
diese spiritualität oder in diese in das
eröffnungs momentum zu bringen und zu
spielen
wir sind eins eben aus dass diese diese
aktualität auch ein stück weit kommt zu
können per soap star interessiert mich
jetzt natürlich auch noch ihre position
was was mir ganz stark
auffällt ist wie stark der körper auch
hier ins zentrum gestellt wird zur
erreichung der erlösung von diesem kreis
der der wiedergeburten und das ist
natürlich für uns westlich mittel von
westlicher philosophie geprägten
menschen auch speziell wenn immer von
leib feindlichkeit oder leib als fessel
gesprochen wird und das göttliche das
rein geistige ist ja also im buddhismus
ist es ja tatsächlich so dass der körper
aufgegeben wird das ist das ziel ist
nicht mehr wiedergeboren zu werden
während es im hinduismus er so ist immer
bessere wiedergeburten zu bekommen und
am ende eine wiedergeburt mit dem in der
man mit dem mit dem mit der gottheit
shiva oder brava oder so etwas 1 werden
kann
aber ich würde schon noch gerne mal auf
frau richardson zurückkommen und das ein
bisschen kritisch hinterfragen was da
betrieben wird
vor allen dingen das 6 das bild von
sexualität das verrutschen zeichnet das
ist doch eine krasse karikatur
das hat sie übrigens genauso von von
brief von backwaren übernommen das ist
in einem seiner bücher oder in seiner
lehrerin einer lehrerin der karikaturen
angeblich 90
ja das war sagt 90 prozent aller frauen
erleben keinen orgasmus 90 prozent aller
männer haben
frühzeitige ejakulation das ist doch ein
bild was da gezeichnet wird es völlig
überzogen ist und wenn man dann im
gegensatz dazu den leuten sagt wie bei
uns könnt ihr 36 zwölfstündige
reaktionen erleben und dreistündige
orgasmen sexualität ist ein bereich in
dem es viele ängste wünsche und
projektionen gibt und die das wird hier
aufgegriffen und da werden solche
versprechungen gemacht und da muss man
sich schon dass auch dort muss man das
auch schon in zusammenhang bringen mit
dem was frau richardson sonst noch
gesagt hat sie hat gesagt sie sehe ihre
wäre zwölf jahre in poona gewesen er
hätte überhaupt nichts mitbekommen von
missbrauch und drogenmissbrauch und
dergleichen sexuellen missbrauch das
muss man doch wirklich mal das ist das
ist doch eine selbstverleugnung das kann
doch gar nicht sein
ich würde sie uns herzlich gilt dass das
würde es nun gerne durch einen
religiösen die die frau retten ist nicht
hier um sich zu verteidigen
deshalb möchte ich das lieber auf der
seite lassen es gibt die vorwürfe und
hat sie auch damit konfrontiert so kann
sich in sicht
die kurve zu kriegen vielleicht genau ja
um die kurve zu kriegen dann zu zudem zu
den anderen dingen ja in wenn immer es
wenn immer mit irgendwelchen religiösen
oder rituellen praktiken sexualität
verbunden ist gibt es immer die gefahr
des sexuellen missbrauches in
irgendeiner form und wir wissen aus
erfahrung wenn es da keine überwachung
gibt wenn es da keine öffentlichkeit und
keine aussprache gibt dann wird es immer
zu einer solchen situation kommt deshalb
wäre meine frage eben an die
sexualtherapeutin die sich ja auch
tantra therapeuten nennt wie garantieren
sie denn dass es in ihrem bereich nicht
nur bei ihnen persönlich sondern auch
bei ihren kollegen nicht auch zu
missbrauch kommt mögen sie kurz darauf
antworten wir sind eigentlich schon am
ende des gesprächs aber bitte so
garantieren kann man das sowieso nicht
also ich kann einfach ja nur für mich
stellung nehmen und sagen dass ich ja
mit einer großen achtsamkeit am werken
bin und mir bewusst bin dass das sehr
verletzliche räume sind in die wieder
gehen und alles darüber hinaus nein kann
ich kann ich keine verantwortung dafür
tragen aber jetzt gerade auch weil der
ausschuss so stark angesprochen hat hat
er denn in der ausbildung heute noch
spielt er eine rolle oder ist das
gewissermaßen weil er so stark
auffrischen angeht ist es eine andere
generation wahrscheinlich sowohl als
auch also viele der heutigen tantra
lehrer kommen schon auch noch auf
regeneration die stärke in berührung war
mit ausschuss philosophie und trotzdem
glaube ich gibt es da auch ganz neue
strömungen die wegkommen von diesem
dogma
wir sind leider schon am ende dieses
gesprächs ich danke ganz herzlich nach
berlin herr sobisch frau mag und frau
wenn er scheint für dieses gespräch
vielen dank auf den nun folgenden film
freue ich mich besonders wir zeigen
ihnen ein zeitdokument der
ausnahmekünstlerin riesa franklin das
fast 50 jahre unter verschluss blieb
konzentriert voller demut und in ihrer
ganzen soll energie kommt sie uns so
nochmals entgegen genießen sie ihren
sonntag
[Musik]